thanks for having me here today at
strange loop it's my first strange Loop
conference having a good time
I'm going to talk to you today about
spotify's personalization audio platform
and specifically the role structure
sorry is this going in and out too
all good okay
um and the role of infrastructure that
plays in so my name is Josh bear I lead
product for a machine learning platform
that we've just renamed as the Hendrix
platform this talk isn't about that
probably a series of blog posts maybe
later in the year or next year if we get
around to it but essentially it's a
product portfolio that that we we use
for our machine
that our machine learning practitioners
use
I talked
okay
yeah I wanted to give you that context
around Hendricks because the little H in
this slide it'll keep coming up and
that's what it means I got some feedback
when I was doing a dry run with my team
that it was confusing so just set that
context
that's Spotify for the last 10 years uh
all coming up on years I started out as
an engineer building out our data
platform that had transitioned into
product a few years a few years after
that for the last four years been
building out our machine learning
platform
so what I'm going to talk to you today
deals with personalization
personalization is all over Spotify from
the shelves you see at home to the
playlist that you listen to to the
messages that you receive when you first
start joining Spotify
and even the offers when you're banned
your favorite band is in town that's all
driven by ml2 but I'm going to focus on
the recommendation aspects probably
because that's the aspect that's most
familiar to you as a Spotify user
and since this is the strange Loop
conference I'm going to be focusing
particularly about the loops within the
recommendation process Loops that we
call learning loops
so my role at Spotify is to try to
ensure that we maximize the amount of
these learning loops every year
particularly in the ml space I'll talk a
little bit about how my team does that
at Spotify and I'll talk about some of
the challenges we've encountered on the
way to where we are
so first some background information to
Spotify so when I first started doing
talks in the US
2013 about Spotify not a lot of people
used it but I'm curious like how many
folks in this audience are users of
Spotify
wow yeah no no uh no hate if you're not
totally understandable but it's totally
changed over time but just for a little
context we have about 80 million tracks
on our platform we have four million
podcasts we have 400 million plus users
and over 180 territories uh and if
you're a super Spotify fan you might
have seen that this week that we just
launched audiobooks so that's like our
third format that we've played around
with
and our ml usage to set some context
um we have over 80 teams that are doing
ml in some capacity we have about 400
000 pipeline runs per year we have about
50
that are produced 50 000.
pipeline runs
and we are model serving architecture
serves about three million predictions
per second
but first so my topic is recommendations
uh I'll eventually start to get a little
bit technical though by being a product
by trade I wanted to paint a meaningful
picture for you all before I get into
that recommendation aspect
so when I was in my mid-teens I had a
job working at the Baltimore County
Parks Department
uh it was a perfect job for a teenager I
had a bit of hard work to do when I
started my job but then it was mostly
sitting around doing that until the game
ended or the park had to close and
I did do a little bit of work
this is very strange event doing
something different with the mic okay
all right
um
yeah during the times of doing nothing I
mostly listen to music
and lots of music
so every month I paycheck then I'd head
to the nearest tape store and can come
music
correlated strongly with what I liked
and heard from the radio that didn't
work out so well I learned pretty
quickly that your ability to put out one
hit on the radio didn't necessarily
correlate with your ability to produce a
good album
it also mean that my knowledge of music
was pretty limited mostly to what was
popular in the radio
but over time I developed I did this
over time and it started to develop a
relationship with the people that worked
at the tape store
and then notice the type of music I I
bought they noticed the type of music I
listened to and they started to
recommend me uh things based off my
preferences
I even got to know one of the the people
that worked at the store so well that we
look he would lend me his old tapes uh
his live Grateful Dead tapes uh from
from the 70s and 80s
and some of the tapes that he lent me
were total Duds not at all what I liked
but some of the tapes that he left me
were great and I'd go you know buy a
version of my own
um
and eventually this relationship grew
and his recommendations got better as he
got a better idea of my style of music
so maybe you in this audience have
similar experience maybe it was with
records maybe with CDs maybe MP3s but
you might have an idea of how this
process works and if you understand how
that recommendation Loops you've
basically understood how our Spotify
recommendation work except instead of
one user and one clerk what expert
system to determine those
recommendations we have data from our
hundreds of millions of users looking
over our 100 millions of of content
to recommend the basic the best music
tracks albums and more
okay
so let's get started walking through the
Journey of Music recommendations at
Spotify
so our app started out pretty simply
looking
yet the offering was pretty Monumental
the idea that almost any song or artist
that you could think of was just a click
away from instant playback
this was in the era of LimeWire and
torrent remember where if you use those
things it would often take minutes or
hours to get the content that you wanted
and sometimes you'd end up downloading
something it wasn't at all what you were
expecting
the Spotify experience felt magical
and even better it was legal the labels
had actually signed off on it
but anyway the initial experience was
very basic you could search you could
see top list you could create your own
playlists nothing here was personalized
though
but what was done is that the events
were instrumented
and what do I mean by instrument
so this is more or less what the app at
the time
you hope you open the app it served your
pages like your library or what's new
you clicked whatever song or album you
wanted to play and we served you that
music
but what you might not know which was
one of the most important things from a
business perspective is that we
collected these events that are called
end songs
now end song sounds exactly probably
like what it is it's a multi-fielded
event that it gets triggered when a
playing song ends whether it be by
skipping a track picking a new track
closing the app anything
this event was incredibly important to
us we could aggregate to know which
songs were played the most and use it to
actually play the labels and of course
we could use this as a basis for our
recommendation systems
so we don't just collect end song
information we're collecting all sorts
of stuff
all sorts of stuff about the tracks that
you're listening to we're collecting
information about the relationships
between artists the tracks
the albums the the genres and more we're
even collecting information that's
crawled from the web around reviews and
the relationships that they might
mention in the reviews
we're even collecting information about
the audio itself the raw audio and using
that to seat some recommendations
and this whole process is actually where
I came in
um all that information was fed to our
Hadoop cluster which I worked on
building out and growing in my early
years at Spotify
once that data was on the cluster the
journey didn't stop there we had all
sorts of job cleaning doing aggregations
joining different data sets
analyzing usage features and baby
behaviors to see what was right people
were doing with the app and all that was
generating more data in the cluster
and from all those jobs we could apply
all sorts of machine learning algorithms
to come up with novel models those
models would be surfaced in the
application to the user
we were heavily into
early on we were heavily into
collaborative filtering models to
generate a lot of our personalization
I'm not going to go into detail in
exactly what collaborative filtering in
I'm sure that half the audience here
probably could do a better
but for some folks just to give you a
basic idea you take this master massive
Matrix representing all our users 400
million or so all the tracks 80 million
or so and you try to fill in missing
values based off of what other users
might like and you expect this user to
listen to
over time we added a few more techniques
to our products I can't keep up with all
the different techniques that we're
applying today
but certainly we're using a lot of NLP
methods gnns
Etc and I know there's a lot of just
interesting stuff going on
and over time this use of ml has led to
many advances of the products so in 2008
we started to feed those end songs the
relationships with other blogs and stuff
related artist features 2011 and 2012 we
built out the radio feature that was
based off a lot of machine learning 2013
we innovated on
which when I started really cool and in
2015 we took that discover product and
we put a playlist around it
creating what was then our Discover
weekly
I'm going to turn up my phone just in
case that happens to be
the source of the interference
okay and now we're at a point when
machine learning is virtually everywhere
in the application
here's a screenshot I took a little
while back about my own home
personalization page the different
colors represent different systems that
are all doing machine learning
so we have the orange there that
represents these massive Ensemble
systems like home and search
we have grain that represents different
ranking systems so in the home page we
rank different content the different
shelves that come up for you based off
of different models
we have fuchsia that represents a few
personalized playlists so these are all
driven by Machine learning and then
there's usually like a filter at the end
that makes sure that we're recommending
you stuff that you haven't listened to
or maybe that's all sort of fit a
playlist
um
we have yellow that represents these
curated playlists by our expert curators
they're actually using machine learning
in a few different ways one way is that
you might have one of these massive
playlists like dinner classical music
and that actually on our end might be
500 songs that our curators say is
dinner classical music but we know that
serving a playlist of 500 songs isn't
very feasible so we might reduce that
down to 60 or so the more playlist shape
and we do that 60 sort of filtering
based off of your own personal tastes
and your user vector
uh also another way that we use ml is
our curators we'll use machine learning
to populate a song so if you're a
curator and you're trying to create some
you know St Louis conference listing
playlist you might have five or six
tracks you know probably Nellie's going
to be there somehow you might seat it
with five or six tracks that fit this
genre and then we have machine learning
help you recommend other tracks that
they can listen to and say yeah this is
really really very similar
so machine learning is really all over
the place
now I'm going to zoom in on the
personalization and how the machine
learning actually factors in and
talk how we build infrastructure to make
this process go smooth maybe it
and again since it's the strange Loop
conference I'm probably going to be a
little bit corny and focus in on those
Loops there this is my first conference
so I don't know if that's overdone so
apologies if it is
so in particular I'm going to talk about
these various Loops that form that
picture on the right now don't worry too
much about what the picture is I'll go
through sort of completing it one by one
of these next few slides
so let's start with the basics how does
machine learning start out the first
thing is what I'm called the problem
understanding Loop you need to start
with a problem to solve you need to have
a metric to measure your progress and
you need to have some existing data to
form the basis of a model
you might go through a few iterations to
this before you come to a place where
you feel comfortable with your Baseline
problem metrics and data it's completely
normal to come out back to this Loop
even after you've built something out
it's also completely healthy and
expected to come away from this loop
with a determination that either you
don't have the data you needed to pursue
an ml approach or you don't have a
problem that ml can actually really even
help out with
the latter issue can lead to a very
costly wasted time and frustrated
Engineers if not held in check the
formation former issue lack of data is
actually something that can be addressed
with another loop
that's the data collection Loop
so when collecting data you might start
out super simply as we did with Spotify
just collecting the end songs that
served the foundation of many of our
recommendation systems
after you have a baseline for some data
to validate the idea the approach and
the metrics Etc it's time to start
thinking about building an ml system
so you create a service that does
something maybe it generates the
smoothest Yak Rock tracks maybe it
orders the home page to keep it simple
we'll just say that it serves the
service returns some sort of prediction
and at this point we'll actually go
ahead and introduce some basic building
blocks for where a model fits in there
too and where data will help out with
the system
also instrument essentially logging
pieces for a loop collecting what will
eventually serve be the features for our
eventual model
we'll also have some tooling to collect
labels here's a zoomed out view of that
the basic idea is that we're serving
something based off the model and data
and eventually going to be collecting
something representing labels now this
of course is a supervised learning model
that I'm talking about
you can Envision a simple med-trick like
the Click through where the play rate of
songs
this might be used to rank songs in a
playlist based off of the likelihood to
click or play and eventually score on
clicks and plays
and to fill out some more information at
this point we're starting out with
heuristics
okay
uh here is the model
heuristics okay I mean I don't like this
basically a series of if or else then
statements but encapsulated within model
architecture
this could be something like a model
that just Returns the most popular
tracks per region based off of
aggregations and we might have done at
the region level already
so this is really starting to create the
the foundations for an important
learning Loop you can start playing
around with your data and model here and
even change the way that your service
behaves ideally to learn and improve it
so now you have the basic structure for
machine Learning System even though
there's at no actual machine learning
yet
you can move on to this next learning
Loop improving your data this stage is
often the most difficult and
time-consuming for a lot of our ml
practitioners at Spotify data is never
where you need it it's never formatted
the best way it's usually not clean
enough to do something useful when you
first start off with it so you'll need
to fix that or you'll need to find a
data set that's already fixed that
so in this phase I have data or features
experimentation that could include
meaning combining transforming Etc
once you have something you like you'll
need to store it for future use you'll
often come back to this loop as you
build out your machine Learning System
so plugging this Loop in the overall ml
systems building process we see it at
the end there
interacting with our data store feeding
into our model
we've taken a lot of our we've taken our
plain old
popularity and joined it with a table
containing demographic information
so now we can provide a slightly more
personalized system to our user even if
it's not really an MLs yet
we call this Loop
element or feature engineering
so now we have some data we have the
skeleton of our ml system we have a
simple heuristic model but now we want
to get more complex so we might add in
another very familiar Loop to many in
this audience the model training Loop
this is where machine learning comes in
so we have a number of things to do here
we need to do the model selection and
move forward with some model
architecture that fits the shape of a
problem we need to do the training we
need to do some evaluations of the model
basis based off maybe those metrics that
we identified earlier and maybe some
model specific ones that we've added on
so almost never get everything right the
first time so we'll be stuck in this
Loop for quite a while tweaking our data
tweaking our model code analysis code
Etc I've people I've seen people at
Spotify spend weeks or months at this
phase exploring different Frameworks and
different model architectures and
analyzing the results in different ways
that come up with something that
hopefully proves that original
hypothesis
and back to our overall system
it sort of looks like this
I've added a few other things that I
didn't quite mention since this is a
system we've deployed deployed as a part
of a Spotify service so it's actually
sort of feeding music in the OR
interacting with the app
um I might call that an online service
now
if conflict between the online and the
offline data
you can think of offline here being at
data's rest on GCS S3 Etc and online
being on a performant data store like
bigtable or dynamod to be some of the
simple uh
this like many of my slides drastically
oversimplifies the process but the basic
idea is that you try to keep the data
and the Transformations that you're
doing the same right both offline and
online if you don't you're in a world of
hurt when it comes to analyzing the
performance of your model
and understand the performance of your
system
so I've also introduced a little loop at
the bottom there
representing hyper pyramid tuning
especially once you've found a model
that you like you might want to perfect
it with the perfect type of parameters
and that might involve an extra set of
Loops during your training and
evaluation
to illustrate what this might look like
in an ml system our model might take
user listening information and our
knowledge of artists to create something
that we call it Spotify artist Affinity
how much we would expect a user to like
and potentially listen to an artist we
could use that artist Affinity score to
personalize the rankings of different
artists that we show on the home page or
in a playlist or all over the place for
example
okay so here we have a machine learning
up and running but our job doesn't end
there we have even more Loops that I'll
call the evaluation Loop
you might start off with a model that
optimizes for example suggested tracks
plays for suggested tracks but after a
while you realize the more powerful way
to to measure the impact your
recommendations is not by plays but it's
about artist saves or the ads to
playlists
based off your learning you might look
for different features different model
architectures Etc to maximize your
performance so going back into those
previous loops
and recommendation systems that Spotify
offline testing is always much faster
than online testing and what I mean by
online testing what I mean is usually
running an A B test or some sort of
experimentation framework
um
now those tests could take weeks to get
meaningful feedback to get enough
exposure
so in recommendation so what we try to
do is we try to come up with metrics
that correlate the offline performance
with the online performance so that we
can actually
it was quicker applying evaluation Loops
uh based off of our local metric and
then hopefully once we have something
that we really like that we really
believe is going to move the metrics
online we can set up one of those online
a b tests and hopefully move the product
in the way that we would hope
now you can get pretty far with
recommendation recommendation systems
with just those loops
those slides weren't exhaustive but they
hit the major cycles that count them up
when I talked to machine learning
Engineers or machine learning
practitioners
two leather Loops that I'm going to talk
about are what I'd consider more
advanced Loops in the cycle but also way
more powerful
the first is what is easiest to
understand as the models as features and
it's exactly what it sounds like the
output of a model is actually the input
of another model you have two systems
intersecting now this is super powerful
because you can get some really Advanced
features as inputs that you wouldn't
necessarily have just from observing the
data and the instrumentation but it can
also get very complex
at Spotify we have entire teams that
build out these models as features and
they're dedicated to improving the
consumption of their model
quite often we see that the best of our
models today transition to the the
models that are used as features for
future models so that was true of the
original vectors that we came up when we
did all the Matrix factorization uh
stuff in an early discover products it's
been true of the embeddings that we've
done when we did like word to VEC with
discover weekly and so many other
different models
another Advanced Loop is one that I've
come to know is the continuous training
and development Loop
essentially instead of training models
one off or even on scheduled jobs you
immediately start training a new model
once your last one has been deployed
now this can be incredibly useful if the
distribution of your data is constantly
changing and shifting throughout the day
and having a fresh model on hand is
pretty important
now I'll be honest we actually don't do
a lot of this a lot of these at Spotify
there's a few factors to that one factor
is that the cost implications are
usually higher just retraining a model
the second one is that the complexity of
this doing this infrastructure setup we
need teams to be pretty Advanced and
Polished in the practices the third one
is actually kind of on me and my team is
that our ml observability capabilities
aren't quite where we need to have them
to really understand how fast data
distribution is Shifting and if we need
to deploy models on a hourly basis or
more frequently than that
so I do see us moving to uh towards this
Paradigm as we advance those
capabilities and build up our machine
learning observability capabilities
and I think we could actually save money
if we get to a place where we really
understand what the model data
distribution lift uh drift looks like
and we can see how often we need to
redeploy a model and sometimes that
might not be except every few weeks
so those are the loops I wanted to talk
about today they form the basis of our
personalization Improvement
um many iterations through Loops make
better recommendations and hopefully a
better product and that makes our chief
product officer over there Gustav super
super happy and jamming to his Spotify
product
so that's like a super old gift that I
like to use in a lot of my slides it's
kind of an inside joke that yeah okay
various Loops building out a machine
Learning System now I'm finally going to
get to an area that's actually my
expertise how we built infrastructure at
Spotify to support those loops and why
it's important
now I lead the group that we've just
renamed to Hendrix more about like what
a what that signifies uh in a future
series of blog posts or talks but for
now you can just think of it as the
machine learning platform team
so this is our mission statement
um I like what it means but I'm not
super thrilled about the length and I
was thinking that maybe after this talk
I'd simplify it a bit uh to just we make
you live faster because that's kind of
the point we make you Loop faster build
out your machine learning faster get to
you to where you need to go with tooling
we also do some stuff on governance but
that's that's another talk
so our platform is a series of products
for now they're fairly distinct but
we're on a mission to make them blend
together more no need to read all this
I'll get to these products one by one
for now
so remember the problem understanding
Loop
one of the things I first saw when I
started my focus on machine learning
infrastructure was that folks were doing
a pretty poor job here at Spotify we saw
teams try ml for a few Sprints and but
pick a problem that wasn't a machine
learning problem or something that
didn't have data for and they couldn't
create a model
so we created a capability that we call
our machine learning engagement team
their job is to partner with teams that
are starting out their machine learning
experience and either get them on the
path to success ideally using our
machine learning infrastructure tools or
speed them up to to failure now that's a
weird thing to say saying I want people
to to move to failure but I'd much
rather have someone spend a few days
working with my team to get to a place
where they know it's not a machine
learning problem or they don't have data
then weeks on their own uh wasting their
time
so do you remember when I talked about
starting with a simple model to first
set up your machine learning
infrastructure skeleton and start
collecting data we built the tool that
helps out helps that helps teams with
that it abstracts the model portion away
from the service so that we can
independently loop on the data of the
model et cetera without affecting the
service code
this may seem like a small thing but
when we're able to separate those
concerns it allows a service owner who's
usually a back-end engineer and doesn't
know machine learning and the ml
engineer to move faster autonomously and
we're super big on autonomous
being autonomous is Spotify the worst
thing in the world you can do is to
block someone
so the tool that we build for this is
called Salem I know it's a pretty crude
drawing over there it helps out with the
deployment of models logging and
features the validation of the models
and the serving architecture Etc it has
close integration with our feature
storage tooling which I'll talk about a
second so that if you train a new model
with a new set of features you won't get
a mismatch in the features of the models
when you deploy something new
it has also tight Integrations with our
experimentation framework so that when
you have a model that's associated with
experimentation a B test you get all
that information fed back to you and you
have it's easier to analyze
and maybe more usefully it helps our
machine learning practitioners ex scale
their model out to these 200 million uh
million users in those 200 million
territories
so it's a really really piece of
cool so for the feature selection Loop
we have a product that standardizes the
way you read and you write features
I standardize the way you manipulate
them using transformation and the way
that you discover new features or you
share your features with different teams
to use
and we call that tool jukebox
jukebox offers a number of basic helper
functions for dealing with features
including dealing with feature prep
joining reading storing to Common stores
it also adds some more advanced features
store functionality like the ability to
register and discover features with
tight Integrations with Salem it helps
you out when you're performing these
loops and introducing new features on
our models it also helps out with
feature reuse so if you've registered a
feature using our jukebox system we make
it easier for someone else to use that
in their machine Learning System that
might they might just be starting off
with
so jukebox not only saves you manual
toil when spinning up new feature
infrastructure but it also enables you
to make other teams development Loops
shorter after all there's no shorter
Loop than the one that you don't have to
take and if you're reusing a feature
that's already known good and it's
associated with production you can skip
one of the most most difficult time
consuming points of feature engineering
um
and you're you're off faster
so next we step to our model training
Loop now there's a lot of moving Parts
here data pipelines intersect with model
Frameworks we might need to train or
evaluate using specialty Hardware such
as gpus or tpus we might need to use
different libraries for different model
algorithms
and to help containerize some of the
moving Parts invest in a tool that we
call Q flow or that is called Q flow and
as you might guess it's kubernetes based
and deals with the model training
aspects
now we can use it to chain together
model training and batch interfer of
inner inference steps producing a new
data data set from a newly trained model
we also use tensorflow extended in
within the context of kubeflow tfx is
built for a scalable production
pipelines and as many libraries that
help our teams build resilient ml
systems now one thing I should mention
is these two last tools Q flow and tfx
are open source are produced by Google
in the case of tfx the other ones always
talk about jukebox sales are stuff
that's sort of internal to Spotify so
you can actually use tfx and qflow
yourself
so finally for the overall iteration
Loop we have all these tools that we've
mentioned before plus a few helper
system
the first tool that we provide is a tool
called Emma home it's a centralized view
of machine learning that's going on in
Spotify but also a zoomed in View to a
team's ml project it helps them
understand how models perform over the
time how their models perform against
different metrics
it allows you to slice and dice
different metrics to understand the
Nuance within the model I like to call
this tool the face of our machine
learning platform because it also
provides ui's elements to other products
that I've talked about
so we pair Emma home up with our
metadata service I think it's an unsung
hero in our platform not only does it
allow us to link together various
components the ammo lifecycle it also
connects with the metadata ontology of
our backend and our data systems
now one of the questions I often get
when I do talks about our machine
learning infrastructure Spotify is why
we built so many of these tools when
there are products out there that do
offer very similar capabilities
my first answer is that when we started
to build these tools out those products
just didn't exist in the marketplace so
there really was no alternative the
second uh answer that I give is that the
tight Integrations that we create
between our backend services our data
services and all that actually provides
a substantial leverage and gives us an
advantage that those third-party
products just don't have
okay okay so I'm done talking about
spotify's infrastructure why is that all
important right here's another way to
view the ml lifecycle
these four stages of a system
development that form another loop
we regularly survey our internal ml
Spotify practitioners about the usage
and the progress with machine learning
and early on we saw some pretty
concerning things like that teams are
spending one to three Sprints which are
usually around two weeks just getting an
initial model prototype out
now that's a concern for impatient teams
which PM wants to wait over a month to
see some initial results
it's worse when it comes to
productionizing of ml systems as you see
in the Highlight here
what we saw early on is that over 30
percent of ml practitioners we surveyed
spend over a quarter turning their idea
into productionized software
now think about that it's it's more than
a quarter to ship out something that
you've already validated and believe
that's worthwhile to ship to production
that's pretty nuts
and if you learned one thing so far
during my talk it's that what really
goes on in that ml lifecycle Loop is a
series of all these different sub loops
and chained together those sub-loops add
up to the time that it actually takes to
build out those machine learning systems
and in our last survey or in one of the
surveys that we ran we saw some teams
spending up to 14 weeks productionizing
their tool now the progress was just a
sum of all those little sub loops
so if we can introduce these Hendrix
tools and make them
make the teams move faster whether by
enabling them to reuse existing features
reuse components in ml system or rely on
Salem for the model deployment and
scaling we can drastically speed up
those inner loops and affect the entire
project Pace it's really all about the
loops
so that's what we do with Hendrix we
make people Loop faster through the ml
process we make them more productive and
Aid them to be build more maintainable
systems and hopefully if we do our jobs
right and we hire great people that will
result in better recommendations for you
across the Spotify product
so thanks for your time today I hope you
learned a little bit about spotify's
personalization journey and how we
started off with a simple interface just
collecting information that we use as a
basis for future product innovation
those product Innovations were the
results of these many learning loops and
the recommendation systems as I
described in the second section
originally all those Loops were unaided
or minimally aided by infrastructure so
it took a long time to result in a
shippable product and that's why we
invested in infrastructure which I
talked about in that third section
and this infrastructure has come far but
still we have a ways to go to make our
ml Partners even more efficient in their
jobs
now if any of those signs interested to
you I'm obligated to say that we're
hiring just ping me afterwards or check
out our jobs site for details now that's
all the time I have today it looks like
I have about eight minutes for questions
uh four minutes for questions thanks for
your time
thank you
so the question was does our ml actually
listen songs so we have quite a lot of
teams uh they're mostly research based
that do do a lot of analysis on the
songs if you've ever used the playlist
release radar release radar is kind of
like discover weekly but it's all new
songs it actually used quite a bit to
analyze some basic understanding of some
um some yeah like attributes of the song
I can't even remember what they are but
there's like bounciness liveliness I
don't know they're all sorts of
different metrics so we use that to feed
some of the uh that pipeline we actually
also use some of the audio information
itself to disambiguate artists which is
another really interesting topic that
metadata that we get from labels is
usually pretty terrible so we can't
necessarily tell if you know this one I
think the example that we use often is
Rome like if this Rome is you know a
rapper or some like synth artist in in
London uh so by listening to the audio a
little bit
um we can figure out that
uh
the question was do we ever encounter
artists that submit uh music to that
caters the algorithms
um that's probably a little bit outside
of my expertise I would say we probably
do I mean I know like a lot of people
listen to sleep music or ambient music
and there's a lot of people that Target
that there's definitely a lot of people
that Target our search algorithm
um I think there's like this one guy
that has a happy birthday song for like
a thousand different names you know so
there's definitely people and if I was
smarter early on in my journey I would
have done that stuff like named album or
Name the artist like punk rock because
we didn't have genre search early on and
so like people with these very generic
names are getting a lot of plays
uh so yes
um two minutes more I'll take one in the
back
how much of the playlists for a machine
learning model and put a machine
learning model uh so in some cases it's
pretty significant uh so I know a lot of
discover weekly I think there are a lot
of other talks about it playlists really
powered a lot of our initial discover
weekly phases but we're constantly
launching in New Market so we realized
that when we're launching those new
markets people were having a pretty poor
discover weekly experience I remember
for example in Brazil which I don't know
we launched in 2017 or 18. discover
weeklies were terrible because it was
mostly Western sort of American European
music that we're recommending we found
over time that we needed to change that
as we launched in markets and come up
with different algorithms that would uh
seat a better personalized experience
yeah so the question was about our
engagement team and how often we find a
problem that's not solvable from ml I'd
say that it's getting reduced over time
as we have more sort of centers of
gravity around machine learning locally
in different offices I'll just tell a
quick story so when we first started out
this team
offices are were split pretty much
between Stockholm and New York and
Boston to some degree and most of our
machine learning was happening in New
York and Boston and the Stockholm teams
weren't we're just kind of experimenting
I remember talking to someone that
wanted to play around with a left-handed
layout because he thought machine
learning is Magic and that you know just
using machine learning we could create
this left-handed layout determining
people were left-handed and come up with
something great after a while of talking
to them and trying to understand more
about the problem we realized that they
had never validated that anybody even
wanted a machine a left-handed layout or
like that that was something useful to
do in the product so we offered them to
First create a button that people could
select to do that and if they validated
it then maybe then we could use machine
learning that would come up with an
actual prediction if someone is
Left-Handed or not so we had probably a
lot of those sorts of things early on
but yeah there was this big idea
especially like 2018 and 2019 when the
hype cycle was crazy the machine
learning was magic and they could just
throw the these problems that they
couldn't figure out you know machine
learning edit would be successful so
yeah that's uh I want to leave plenty of
time for the next speaker to set up
thanks for your time and I could
probably go out in the hallway if you
have more questions cheers